turn your phone off god dammit
hi everyone welcome back to resin
knievel the air quality check the San
Francisco I'm Eric Tay this is Rob
handler here we're in the backup studio
today as you can tell there's a couple
of big-screen TV behind us the lights in
the back are not completely working yeah
I was married while he controls really
gone downhill yeah Eric marry Rob is
going is traveling tomorrow so we and
also like it's Thursday and they buy
this place on fire yeah air quality and
San Francisco is pretty bad wait what I
put it up here it looks like I work at
like good burger welcome to good burger
home of the good burger can I take your
order back with a more normal Pip today
if you do not react to the things that I
say it's going to get weird I know I'm
just like yeah you're doing a good
burger yeah no that doesn't doesn't
count you have to care wow this is bad
hold on why does the gameplay look like
it's really lagging it's lagging yeah
hold on let me look like watch they run
Thanks okay all right yeah all right
cool it's worth a concern but I think
we're okay do you remember what happened
at all so I was getting pretty tired I
might need a refresher course but like
for anyone who's like joining us and
being like wait when did you start
playing this we played the very first
episode for five hours during extra life
I also have Invisalign in now so I have
a slur so enjoy dark so we are already
like six hours in yeah you can watch
that episode it's up on YouTube now it's
five and a half hours the episode we did
have a few other people on the couch
with us I think overall everybody liked
the format for a live episode definitely
you'll also notice people yeah people
like that we had guests on so we should
definitely do a guest once or twice now
unfortunately we changed up the game
woody would you call it what we normally
have been playing four by three aspect
ratio but this one is sixteen by nine so
we have to go back to our traditional
pick pip old-school pip because that way
you guys don't lose any screen what the
[ __ ] he's trip oh I thought it was a
glitch it was like an invisible force
field did you see that
now I understand it's a new type of
hunter they really like doing that how
would I know where they are
oh I see snow this is audio sound weird
to you yes I can only hear it it's I
think so this is the first time this
PlayStation specifically has been used
as a new pro that I we got in the office
so it might still be on those the wrong
audio settings do you think that you
could the people at home will also have
this problem I'm not positive I can
check the settings are you gonna on the
PlayStation yeah yeah you pause I can go
to our camera ok wait let me age should
I finish this fight sure oh my god I'm
gonna die
like I said bear with us this is the
backup studio and we kind of had to
throw everything together at the last
minute they tried to do something
oh it's backflip
I'm really running out of bullets
there's a herb okay sorry
so is Basel a camera
what oh good boy cuz I gotta go to my
playstation yeah I know I was supposed
to do anything yeah this is my good boy
sweater I got it from the Golden Gate
lab rescue cuz I do charity work for
them they save golden they save golden
labs any labs actually that's not true
they don't have to be golden
what's this ass discretionary oh they
save labs in the Golden State area Dulux
thank you they put them in they take
ones that are in like bad homes or like
you know sometimes there's like not
being taken care of and they put them in
good homes and they save them from kill
shelters everyone should know
Golden Gate Lab rescue is the best lab
rescue organization they're really
sounding screen thank you and audio
output it's probably still on the yeah
go do it here yeah make that good suebdo
buddy try that classic Dolby actually go
to HDMI out just I'm just assuming
that's fine come on optical or I don't
know HDMI out seems good because that's
what we use you have the stream okay
like I like when things are HDMI out
yeah okay anyway that should be good
let's try I don't think I thought you
papa Mary died sorry
somehow I thought you pause it I thought
I did too didn't I I thought
watch it looks like a glitch yeah it
does yeah it doesn't sound good I can't
believe they're gonna well if I leave
him I can't hear him I think it's game I
think it's in the game does that make
sense yeah it's in the game okay
so we're fine I feel confident that
we're fine I don't think people mind if
it's not
you can't hear your gun no can you like
barely oh my god
sometimes this game I feel like I'm
watching like one of those Rick and
Morty commercials where he's like do you
have a play a game but you can't see
them that's because they're invisible
you see you're not gonna be able to
shoot them if you can't see them that's
why I invented no but seriously I don't
I can hear your gun
I can't no well that's just the magic
when I try one more thing or just go I
can't see him uh like actually finish
this fight this time and then I did now
the music is still playing
gotcha [ __ ] he did okay
that's definitely not right well it's
like I can hear what I'm no I know but
you can't even hear your gun shooting
and that's like that weird oh let's do
one more thing yeah see that's all just
you know the game audio looks fine yeah
it's just I think it's the PlayStation
just go into the settings one more time
this happened with red dead red that's
default was super weird
and this PlayStation is literally out of
the box fresh on the box my teeth hurts
so bad
all right what do you want to try so
digital out go back go to the audio
format
yeah make sure you're gone if you know I
think it's still weird I heard it yeah I
mean you can hear it but this alright
okay where I'll try to mess with it and
like I'm telling you it sounds fine um
[Music]
so wait did you have to do like the
drill thing the screw like the for
Invisalign cuz there's a procedure you
could do before you do it that
accelerates it by six months yo and it
my girlfriend did it and she it was the
most pain she's ever been in her life
you want to hear what they do sure so so
your as yours like a year long thing or
six months uh it's about six months
maybe even less so what's hurting how's
it hurting Oh cuz it's like a retainer
normal ready throat a ting her so
there's a thing you can do at the
beginning of Invisalign where they
literally drill into the bones above
your teeth like drill holes and then
like the one here one here one here one
here and it will accelerate the teeth
rotation because they're like healing
and then it'll cut down
time by like several months and my
girlfriend did it to speed it up and she
said it's the worst pain she's ever felt
sounds awful yeah well I'd like to drink
this beer but I'm not allowed to do it
with my Invisalign can you you want me
to drink it for you
it's so embarrassing look you want me to
that's one delicate yeah that's the one
word I would use to describe what you
just did
sweet
cool well here's to good times yes
and a Michelob Ultra all that pain for
us four percent oh and if I keep my
teeth on the table why just don't forget
them they put little pieces of concrete
on my teeth well done dots a heat phone
Chris here I received the coordinates
that's not the whole thing sucks the
whole process is like awful I just
wanted straighter teeth by a little bit
oh you're back to Chris and yeah what's
her name
good those guys were what a quick
episode well I think we ended like
halfway through it
oh yeah you're probably right
[Music]
nothing but a what do you think of that
boss fight from last time the comms
officer are you talking about the guy
who was that took me a couple tries cuz
I didn't know I had just like a Baldy
handle on the world sass sass no no I'm
everybody has that experience he just
takes a lot to kill I wasn't making
funny no right I didn't think you were I
was reading my soul this is how bold
revelations
what took you to so
at least we're here what's up with
Beltran
I can't shoot them because I can't see
them oh yeah you were in the waterlogged
[Music]
yeah they got trapped in there that's
captain jackass that's major jackass to
you well that was helpful because now I
understand everything it is good to know
that looks like a penis
but yeah the going back to that boss
fight it was really frustrating to go
through every frickin bullet and still
not kill him and I know I could have
done it better
shown by the fact that I killed it on my
second try I just need to understand
what I forgot about the butts in this
game holy God yeah where's the rest of
her suit remember um [ __ ] what's her
name she's wearing those fancy clothes
oh they're on the same tankers are you
kidding me oh she's trying to she'd
being all coy no not in that outfit
she's wearing one of those airplanes
neck pillows let me see your butt
I think she knows what you're trying to
do you're back in Christmas shoes again
where else what's with this music at the
beginning of a chapter it is stressful
all right let's take the stairs baby
like how come you never see a guy with
like a shirt that's like up to here so
you can see all his boobs and stuff I
don't know but I'd love to see it Chris
is showing off his 12 pack clothes have
just never been for the women it's
always for the dudes like I'd like to
get a nice sneak peek too you know yeah
I don't blame you she looks like someone
who definitely has killed Dalmatians for
a coat yeah or a chinchilla she's just
it doesn't look like a good person
alright there's a safe all right so
we're looking for a card reader
yeah this music does not match what's
going on here it's interesting choice
what do you you're looking for a card
reader to get into the safer through the
door into this safe well we were
learning a lot here been playing a lot
of hitman - there's a mission on a boat
is it good it's so good I finished my
first hitman I've heard wonderful things
about it [ __ ] love it I get it now
why everybody likes that serious
everybody likes that series alright I
obviously missed something what did I
miss that you got your map shows the
destination it might show the lotto are
those probably something in this bridge
yeah oh yeah there's like a little box
in here I didn't see I guess or is that
the safe no it's not
excuse me I'm gonna clear my throat
allall right now I am not having a great
time with my voice because of the air
yeah walk outside I I was in a meeting
and my voice just straight cut out and I
couldn't talk anymore it was
embarrassing I'm assuming everybody
knows but it's cuz there's like really
crazy fires all over don't fart are
terrible the worst of the state's
history people 60 now it's like I think
it's the worse than this imagine all
this port oh look where you are sorry I
just need to cut off that
look where you are cuz the comms
officers boss arena she's just talking
to me like there's not as gross in there
Guillermo del Toro
get shot in the butt all right I need a
better guy
well
what was that
Oh scan him while he's alive okay did I
do it no really I don't have time Oh
Brent oh that's that was unfortunate
wasn't it
you can heal the triangle
Oh always a [ __ ] kind of news in this
room walking there just is this the
things this is what's gonna happen
there's gone or do they keep coming I
don't think so unless you want to go to
the opposite side of the room far to
your right got you [ __ ]
yeah go that way ish but on the ground
floor
I can think I can jump off here no no
you need oh there's her but look
oh wait damn it oh yeah that's nice come
on what it see have 11 rounds left in
this whopper you just say no what is she
saying come on
like maybe I'm supposed to app maybe I'm
supposed to like not be here yes maybe
I'm supposed to kill them yeah there's
nothing no there's nowhere else to go I
don't think
music is still scary
I can't remember very scandalous [ __ ] oh
[Music]
that closets a little left they have
that door oh yeah yeah oh there's
another door - you're right - I remember
coming in here
who
yeah
but where are all the baddies remembers
that not a door back there where you
pick up there I mean it's a door but
it's closed
doesn't look open II
I'm sure there's like the music still
stressful
maybe I wasn't supposed to fight those
now you were maybe upstairs again like
I'm just looking around purveying the
area doing my due diligence concerns
now's not the time oh I guess the music
would be crazy because you're going to
save them while they're drowning right
I'm wasting a lot of time that makes
sense as you pick up Amma I mean you got
to do what you got to do
they are dead
is this am I supposed to know where to
go like don't back oh it's a grenade
down by that door hold on Jill yeah my
priority don't worry he's just on the
toilet I'm coming don't worry
[Laughter]
that's disguise loading screen
oh my god that lower that guy's face
when he communicates with me look at him
yeah he's a really ugly dude they made
that on purpose like I had no chance in
the bilge do you know where the bilges
head for the belch yeah okay man we be
looking for that bilge
where's the [ __ ] bilge
[Music]
oh there it is yes I guess through the
casino looks like uh what do you mean
through here and then down
these doors take so long to open
yeah it's pain
she looks ridiculous what's that noise
it's one word for it
ooh a herb yeah but oh they gonna pop
through that door
oh my god
[Music]
stay the hell away ugly
[Music]
watch out dumb-dumb
it's got a chainsaw yeah
shoot the babies
[Music]
she in trouble yeah they shot some
manner with the travelers these guys
against the convo how do I run do you
worry
yeah actually I don't think so kids baby
don't really have a lot of ammo for this
Oh pungent
I can't
I should have should have thank God that
wasn't a one hit like other chainsawed
listen if you're talking about that one
incident and read to me before I don't
want to talk about it when you were
dusting
I think did you check his ball I cut
that [ __ ] red rope roped off an area
I couldn't get through you got a velvet
velvet tape sorry I'm VIP he's not with
me hey do I have enough ammo to do this
yeah I'm gonna use that grenade oh [ __ ]
I used to were you there
was I there I'm watching it yeah
[Music]
stay the hell away weird way to say that
quick I need to know how to run there's
gotta be a run
like I can't run I think we figured it
out there next oh I thought look it up
oh my god
Oh No
[Music]
nope there is no run button
[Music]
these guys can run [ __ ]
[Music]
oh my god this is hard I'm like
[ __ ] see like that guys kneeling but I
can't
[Music]
that
like it's just right I'm doing this
right right yes we have grenades
remember yeah
[Music]
my god don't come from the other way
[Music]
yeah so like a lot like one thing to
remember is this is a part of a 3ds game
so there weren't as many button options
even with the Circle Pad Pro
[Music]
yeah Oh get punch yes
[Music]
okay cool we do it oh you [ __ ] idiot
one of them vomited up 80 telex is that
the key you need for upstairs
I would assume no you still you have to
go to the tour the film still maybe it's
right there
Oh a Trident key
okay sorry all right cool
I'm sending it work email me too you
were sending a work email in the form of
a bullet in the back guys head in boxes
this is a creepy room and that's a
creepy thing
it's pustules don't be near him when he
dies I can't it oldest trick in the book
nice oh you [ __ ]
I'm forgetting to scan I'm gonna not
them it's hard to who's scared that sack
give me some scale boy here's Gotham
Hill
I like don't want to scan right now
there's like gross [ __ ] going on oh [ __ ]
I'm out of [ __ ] ammo like 100 percent
like 115 AIDS we're just dodge just run
back you got me with his neck oh god
where am I going
probably heal oh no there's an item
sorry threw a grenade point-blank his
face I'd have nothing oh you're here
whoa I have how can they not give me any
ammo for this scenario is this intended
yeah he's this game design you might
have been right about running through
that first area Oh like I wasn't
supposed to shoot anybody I mean I think
if you can you have the option to not
oh great elevators we have a great
history with those oh my god that butt
current time
they're just service
suck your [ __ ] dick I don't care
[Laughter]
Michael Oates get to you quick is this
right
Parker is such an idiot I don't know I I
know
Turner you're in a rush to go see Parker
why's that
trying to save some people maybe I
should check the map mmm
am i going the wrong way oh you right
here on the right way he just
I hope this is there some handgun ammo
good cuz there's some what was that
lever do the incinerate him or something
that would be cool
[Music]
oh great
[Music]
then move what
[Music]
goddammit
[Music]
can you shoot the lever something like
wide open pocket or shoot one of those
exploding guys and words
[Music]
don't worry J like kayaks got and this
stuff real fast you know yeah I do my
job
science
[Music]
I [ __ ] have no bullets I can't do
this
grenade him nice nice
right near stupid I oh my god
I'm coming Jill don't you worry you're
like thank you
oh there's some aah machine gun mm Oh
a lot of em over there grenade that one
dude this in here yeah they get all that
sweet ammo
he'll wait there's too many 800k that
grenade hit me a little bit shotgun
shotgun
it's a jackal
[Music]
oh [ __ ] I wasted so much that's right
what now they throw ammo at you
Oh Jessica Oh hit him kick him I didn't
know I could
this music is really getting on my
nerves
I'm coming we're gonna save you hold
your breath for Southers six minutes oh
my god these are only worth a percent
apiece yeah well you already seeing that
bunch up okay now run oh you can sorry
yeah just go just go
hello Jayla be nice to get help
oh my [ __ ] god
I don't know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] nuts area yeah they funny that's
like skinning their drowned corpses it's
a damn shame
this damn shame Jill was worth 45%
though
fire exploding other lights never
[Music]
so wait they got out is that what has so
I thought your on this is an obeah is
that a different ship now
oh yeah go for another like 10 ish
minutes
if they make me hit a button really
quickly let me know
[Music]
[Music]
how does it let me know when I'm running
out of air I don't know
start beating the [ __ ] out of Parker
[Music]
very few times in the history of video
games has a water level been a good idea
[Music]
Parker do something you worthless second
[ __ ] [ __ ] did en [ __ ] [ __ ] wait what do
i do I
what am I supposed to do tell me what to
do I have a grenade
no don't you create she's gonna die yeah
as their plight is there something else
down on the bottom I'm dying all right
there comes something shining I died I'm
sorry they're small they're sweet now we
know there's something else down there
it's dying a lot this episode you'll die
if you can't breathe what it's a fog did
they hit WebM and D up for this game
so much for Chris helping out we're just
saving ourselves after all that
help me anybody it was me who write the
last cheese it okay so we are looking
for a crowbar forget her pipe whatever
and then you said there was something
else there was but I think you got you
know there you go
you got to use the you got to open the
try the great first and then come back
me at that are you serious
just do a willing pipes wonder she died
[Music]
don't go down
go down oh this is frustrating
really it is Oh No where was the pipe I
thought it was on that side I can't pick
up two [ __ ] pipes like honest
[Music]
yes hi yay she's out Parker comes up and
she just dunked his head back down and
kills him when I say don't suck your
dick I was joking
it's just kidding
Oh
the clean there's a demo in this
abandoned daddy I was lucky dog treats
back in water
I'll figure the audio out for next time
it's alright I mean as long as I can
read it I feel yeah
I hope those vaginas are gone those
things are gross first time I have ever
said that okay
I'm definitely not the first nor last
what was I doing what's my goal that
those
but toward that orange thing on the map
I guess would you Parker just save you
oh yeah it's that sweet
I hear it I wonder how much they'd be
worth that's no regrets giant piranha
they're [ __ ] doing work
gachi little [ __ ] probably kill if
you want to
got it 11 got it hoho good eye and the
hot seat go I got it
I'm very badly using her right now
you think yeah yeah I don't even have
red on you work you totally have red all
over the screen wait a minute okay
I'm healthy as a clam how do I open this
l1 is a knife I think no nope sorry
that's r1
I think that's throwing a grenade
controls Oh what there was a controls
person damn it oh come on
isn't it go to go up now press triangle
Oh smart aren't r2 that might have been
helpful no it's the whole game I mean I
probably would have used it more to
powers back
whoo there were just right here I do
like when they intersect storylines by
like like being a little bit of time
difference is really like in resmio 6 or
serendipity just like in Resident Evil's
evil 6 that's the one mouths damn it
it's on the observation deck maybe we
can fix it
I'm sure the view is nice she just
winked at and when she said that let's
move
they're from the whole
what am i doing
going up to the observation deck would
that be back the way I can to the right
yeah that one I believe
Oh God
that's so [ __ ] rude
I like the rifle in this game it's just
it's quick you know it's like wait this
one yeah it feels really nice to shoot
it's like my favorite gun so far I
normally prefer shotguns just because
they're they're widespread and like yeah
it's like got a nice knock back to it
but I'm like taking the yeah but anyway
I like the rifle in this game was the
point of that story
next floor menswear
we're on the Queen Semiramis
[Music]
wait that's why they're on the wrong
ship I get it now okay quit learn there
were two ships during the classic mix-up
oh my god we were on two different ships
the whole time Nicky no but I've got my
top people on it for driving together in
search here see what you can find Roger
that
our [ __ ] leg what a fun how much more
time do you have 15 minutes run tight
schedules today oh I actually should be
using these shouldn't I
oh wait do I need to be in a box to do
this I need to be in a box to do this I
understand
don't worry cheese don't let me choose
okay good
smart clean Salem you know
what's that noise hey real or is the
better
it got away with it
can you believe that weird dodge a thon
during extra life I do I had a had a
good run actually I just get lucky
oof it's dark in here
didn't get lucky with that boss though
[Music]
all right so there's an upstairs that
ways blocked
it's a giant hole
this was scary to play during extra life
I'm I was impressed with how just how
scary they they made this game it's it
got me pretty good several times I was
like freaking out
the Lord anytime they do this I think
it's actually pretty scary oh yeah I'm
like in a 50s diner [ __ ] my throat oh
let go
I can't is that that they did in the 50s
I have no no no I think you're thinking
of like Hawaii flapper dance or anywhere
else 20s okay any other dance but the
who love do the twist go is it really
time where's Tom
they did the twist you said it like
Kermit you know like that old singer
Tony Bennett forget it Frank Sinatra
maybe some other guy did I already scan
it I already scanned it
[Music]
I'd really use more ammo I hope I'm not
a gun she is alright
all right got two options this one ends
in a dead mm so let's do this one it's
the terrorist group flag Veltro is
written on it
furious instructions yeah we're the
sticky bandits everyone will know every
boat that we've hit quite ma oh i'm
twitter today people are asking like
what your favorite obscure movie line is
and i was talking about how when Joe
Pesci Gio Pesci says from a tree house
for my tree house he's gonna call the
cops from a tree house
go back we said go back a lot securing
the room Intel indicates there could be
a bow spy props to so confusion you've
spy props
I feel like if you want to be stealthy
you probably shouldn't leave your paper
of instructions behind yeah they do that
a lot in this series even during a final
[ __ ] boss fight in the last game God
left that fight
oh right when I got mad yeah but like if
your boss fight needs an instruction
manual you probably didn't design it
well I was frustrated in the last games
boss fight strictly because I felt like
I had really grown from the beginning to
the end of the fight like I was like I
understand how to do the fight now but
it didn't Matt oh [ __ ] its it didn't
matter because by then I had been
punished enough by the AI that it was
not salvageable and I really like a good
like comeback story like I like it when
you can call me Big Poppa yes I like it
when you can figure it out and solve it
and I think it made me sad that like I
figured it out but it wasn't enough to
complete understandable and that's why I
didn't like that most
are you saying last time that seven is
your favorite resonable seven I think
was my favorite ingredient I really
enjoyed it I don't know where I'm going
really God you scared me idiot sorry he
scared me
geez scared me I don't even know where
I'm going I should check oh my god and
Mike [ __ ] going the wrong way
look at this yeah Louis yeah I've been
going the wrong way okay well you're not
making up for any time right now oh how
do I go backwards yeah well no get out
of this stop rotating them yeah I go
back all right no I think you're going
there is this the Rick I don't know the
maps not great yeah I think so no I
don't think you've been going the wrong
way
I haven't I think you just
[Music]
see cuz like this is a dead end isn't it
oh right yeah totally
oh my god I'm so dumb how far out of the
way did I take us that time I thought
that was a zombie
that was me snort sighing there really
aren't any zoms in this game they're all
like weird they're all special infected
which is fine I do think that Dom bees
are like a part of the memories of these
games though right like it's a part of
the whole
maybe I did have to come here because
the elevator is broken right so like I
guess I couldn't have gone downstairs
yeah go to those stairs of the top right
of your map okay I think I bring up the
map again quick how we're not helpful
Matt I know I just keep just keep moving
toward those stairs I just mentioned
this is backwards just so you know like
I've been here and I
oh my god I'm like wasting over about
one more time that's not helping at all
why do the [ __ ] oh no you are here but
this is where I came from like this is
why the whole thing is like frustrating
it's like maybe I was supposed to go
downstairs okay so I can't okay so maybe
I am going the right way but then I
don't know what the [ __ ] I'm supposed to
be because your mouth is where I came
from this is where I came from right
yeah no I see what you mean so you
wouldn't ideally obviously like to go
down but the stairs are out so so I did
have to go up right I don't know hold on
go so you came from the door in front of
you I came from here yeah how positive
are you that's the elevator to the other
way oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] scared mr.
dinner again this is the dead end where
I found out that the guy was a spy right
right all right and then over here there
should be an elevator out of order I
guess you were going the right way
yeah it's just hard to tell honestly cuz
this place is so right here yet yes I
think you're going the right way
I just don't know where else to go we
can keep back-tracing but like at some
point Falls
no this is where it came from
remember remember this is your 50s diner
joke
oh yeah well never mind in that case
yeah I guess go back upstairs in the
where there's like a I think when you
second guessed it that maybe there was a
way I just don't know where else to go
like I can second-guess myself but at
the same time welcome back but where am
I supposed to go oh wait no this looks
better
it's me somewhere confusing yeah like
hey hold on
open your mouth quick there's the hole
right yeah so and here's where I started
I came from this elevator so the
question is should I have not gotten in
the elevator like is this entire area
[ __ ] wasting my life hold on bring
about them so like can I take this
elevator down I don't think so I think
it was bring you up you could try I
don't try it
cuz I don't understand yes I thought you
came from so I did which means I've been
going the wrong way for a really long
time I've been going the wrong way
what happened so let's go alright
nothing matters let's go
alright well I'm glad that I did that
then wasted so much ammo sucks it's like
what was the point of me coming Jesus I
always scares me like was I supposed to
go on this tube is this like a tube
thing mmm because this right yeah I
thought it's were you yeah that's not
where you came from
well look yeah it goes into this tube
and then it should leave me with a
yellow ball who is the guide here is you
the guide what is that
I got I got
oh you got me I'm a my stuff
oh my god I don't know what I was
supposed to do okay so this is where I
[ __ ] up remember god yeah I see what
you mean
so I should never have gotten in this
door yeah my mistake was not like I was
what happens to most of us okay no no no
you see you just did it again the tubes
back there I know where the tube is is
there ammo oh is that like a shocking
upgrade all right so let's talk about
this guy what should I have done
differently cuz that guy killed me
quickly look what weapon you have
machine gun yeah I also have a shotgun
but I don't want to get close to that
[ __ ] I guess I'm just confused because
I felt like I couldn't dodge him yeah
you know what I mean what was that thing
on the wall so explosive
okay so there's a fan here I guess just
shoot him more or shoot those that thing
on the wall next to him come assuming it
blows oh you think so oh that's him you
gotta shoot him his stomach
goddamnit ooh Oh hopefully other one
doesn't hatchet dude oh the one behind
me that I just passed how I bet you he
can't climb these ladder I wanted to say
stairs I cannot hear this guy yeah I
don't like it
all right this is probably a good spot
to save it oh my god what a bad episode
it was all you rescued Jill I did not do
a very good job I'm sorry it's all right
we saved a lot of time on extra life
stuff there's room for was not my best
efforts but I survived yeah all right
cool
well again thank you this is the second
episode of Resident Evil Revelations but
we are like five or six hours in because
we did a lot on extra life thanks for
everything you watch that live and
thanks for anybody who's been watching
it's up on YouTube now it is five and a
half hours so if you have some sort of
road trip or a flight then that's
probably ideal otherwise we will see you
next weekend I believe will we
Thanksgiving and everything's coming up
oh yeah we'll have to figure it out
that's a record actually I'm even in
town on Thanksgiving me too
are you alone do you wanna have
Thanksgiving together
probably yeah okay wait we did the
smiths thing last year after
Thanksgiving I don't remember that we
co-sponsored Smith's cover band you
don't remember that I remember this in
this diagram you got so drunk I have a
video of you dancing
oh you don't yeah I do not on the show
lift your shirt up so that you can see
your but you can't know how could you
see my oh yeah like with pants on no but
you like lifted your shirt so that like
the ridges would show totally and just
telling you what happened I was there I
remember okay cool on that note he will
see everybody next Yeah right next
weekend by doing the wag of the finger
ye were you were like I'm a sassy boy I
can do what I want
I never said nobody nobody tells me what
do